what needs to happen for jordan peterson
to say
i'm kind of leaving canada to go to a
different state would anything happen
that would cause you to leave that place
well i don't think as long as my son's
there i don't think so because that's a
big advantage to being there but we're
doing so much traveling my wife and i
that
in some sense we don't live anywhere you
know i mean we were we were three weeks
two weeks in the uk and then a week in
washington and now we've been on the
road we're going to be on the road
pretty much non-stop till march of 2023
because this the tour ends in the states
in
in at the end of april we'll hit 40
cities and then canada assuming
that's possible but it looks like it
probably will be and then the uk and
europe we're going to be back in canada
for two months in the summer
and then down to new zealand and
australia and southeast asia and then
i'm going to cambridge i believe in
january
to do a seminar on exodus which is what
i wanted to do at cambridge multiple
years ago before they canceled me and
but that's all been sorted out and so it
looks like there's a very high
probability that that will occur
and then that's really as far out as
we've looked so that'd be march of 2023
and god only knows what shape the
world's going to be in at that point
there's hardly any sense in planning out
past that because everything is in such
flux there's no predicting future so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you